.
HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU GUYS AT
HOME ON A MONDAY.
THIS IS "AMERICA'S
NEWSROOM."ENTER THE BORDER
CRISIS IS SPIRALING OUT OF
CONTROL.
ARRESTS ARE HISTORIC LEVELS.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SINGING A
VERY DIFFERENT TUNE FOR ALMOST
TWO YEARS NOW.
>> WE HAVE A SECURE BORDER.
>> THE BORDER IS SECURE.
>> WE HAVE TAKEN UNPRECEDENTED
ACTION OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A
HALF TO SECURE OUR BORDER.
>> THE BORDER REMAINS CLOSED.
IT IS NOT OPEN.
WE'RE TURNING AWAY THE MAJORITY
OF ADULTS.
>> WE HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
MANAGE MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER.
>> Bill: ARRESTS ARE SURGING AND
SO ARE THE NUMBER OF SO-CALLED
GOTAWAYS.
NEW NUMBERS SHOW NEARLY A
MILLION EVADED DETECTION SINCE
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
ALLOWING SO MANY TO DISAPPEAR
INTO THE U.S. AND THIS IS
NOTHING NEW.
>> Julie: YOU'RE RIGHT.
BILL
>> HUNDREDS OF THESE MIGRANTS
CROSSING THE RIO GRANDE IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
>> BORDER PATROL DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH AGENTS TO PROCESS THE
FOLKS.
THE SITUATION IS COMPLETELY
DETERIORATING.
>> MIGRANTS USED A ROPE TO CROSS
THE RIVER SOME CARRYING INFANTS.
>> A FREE FOR ALL.
IF PEOPLE CAN GET ACROSS THE
RIVER THEY CAN WALK IN.
>> THE BUS PULLING OUT NOW IS
FULL OF UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
AND YOUNG TEENAGERS.
>> Julie: HIS RELENTLESS
COVERAGE AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
FINALLY CATCHING THE ATTENTION
OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Bill: YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THIS.
REPORTING SEVERAL CURRENT AND
FORMER WHITE HOUSE AND
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
EXPRESSED INCREASING FRUSTRATION
WITH HIS ON-AIR COVERAGE.
SO FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER SOME
1700 MILES TO CAPITOL HILL OUR
COLLEAGUE WENT TO WASHINGTON TO
ASK QUESTIONS OF THOSE IN CHARGE
OF POLICY.
>> Julie: BILL JOINS US NOW WITH
THE LATEST ON YOUR IN-DEPTH
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN FIRST TOOK
OFFICE, THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS, MIGRANT DEATHS AND
KNOWN GOTAWAYS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER HAVE SURGED TO RECORD
LEVELS.
WE'VE BEEN DOWN THERE FOR A
BETTER PART OF A YEAR AND A HALF
WITNESSING MUCH OF THIS CHAOS IN
PERSON.
NOW WE'RE HERE IN D.C. AND WE'RE
PUSHING FOR SOME ANSWERS.
>> 250,000 UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN ARRIVED AT THE BORDER
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE.
SOME TRAFFICKED AND SOME
DROWNING IN THE RIVER.
ANY ISSUE WITH THAT?
IS THE BORDER SECURE?
DO YOU AGREE THAT THE BORDER IS
SECURE?
WE'LL LET YOU GO.
CHAIRMAN, ONE QUESTION.
IN YOUR OPINION IS THE BORDER
SECURE?
>> I HAVE TO GO GIVE A SPEECH.
>> A QUICK QUESTION.
IS THE BORDER SECURE?
>> ANSWERS ABOUT THE BORDER FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN FROM SOME
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL.
INCLUDING THE SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY MAYORKAS.
>> I'M BILL WITH FOX NEWS.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE BORDER?
>> WE SENT THIS EMAIL TO DHS
NOTIFYING THEM WE WOULD BE IN
D.C. AND REQUESTING AN INTERVIEW
WITH THE SECRETARY.
WE RECEIVED NO RESPONSE.
SO WE WENT TO HIM.
>> A FEW MOMENTS OF YOUR TIME
AND THEN WE'LL LET YOU GO.
REACH OUT TO YOUR OFFICE AND
ASKED TO TALK TO YOU LAST WEEK
AND THEY BLEW US OFF.
900,000 GOTAWAYS.
NO COMMENT, SIR?
>> ONLY DEMOCRATS FROM THE STATE
OF TEXAS, THE FRONT LINE OF THE
BORDER CRISIS, TALKED TO US AND
THEY EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
BORDER.
>> THIS IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
IT HAS BEEN UNSUSTAINABLE FOR
YEARS.
>> WE HAVE RESOURCES DOWN THERE
BUT WE CLEARLY NEED TO BE DOING
MORE.
>> THIS IS OUR ADMINISTRATION,
I'M A DEMOCRAT.
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND THEY OWN
IT NOW.
THEY OWN IT NOW AND THEY HAVE TO
TAKE THE STEPS TO CORRECT THIS
OTHERWISE WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
SEE AN END TO THIS?
>> WE ALSO PUT QUESTIONS TO
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE BORDER IS
SECURE?
>> I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE A SECURE BORDER.
AND I THINK THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO ADDRESS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A PLAN TO
ADDRESS THAT.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD MAJORITY
CONTROL FOR TWO YEARS AND NO
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS ON ANY
IMMIGRATION LEGISLATION IN THE
SENATE.
I ASKED CHUCK SCHUMER WHY THAT
IS THE CASE.
>> REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO DO
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
EVEN ON SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
DACA, WHICH HAS THE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
REPUBLICANS ARE BLOCKING IT.
>> UNDER REPUBLICANS WOULD
AMNESTY OF ANY KIND FOR ANY
GROUP OF MIGRANTS WHO CAME
ACROSS EVER BE ON THE TABLE.
>> NO AMNESTY.
IF NANCY PELOSI WAS NO LONGER
HERE THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS FEEL FREE TO VOTE FOR
A SECURE BORDER AND WORK WITH US
TO HAVE A REAL IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
>> AND MINORITY LEADER MCCARTHY
TOLD ME IF REPUBLICANS END UP
RETAKING THE MAJORITY AFTER THE
MID-TERMS AND HE BECOMES SPEAKER
THEY WOULD NOT MOVE TO
IMMEDIATELY TRY TO IMPEACH
SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
HE SAYS A REPUBLICAN PRIORITY
WOULD BE SECURING THE BORDER
FIRST.
ON DAY ONE THEY WOULD PUSH TO
REPEAL THE HIRING OF 87,000
I.R.S. AGENTS AND INSTEAD FOCUS
ON SERVING RESOURCES DOWN TO OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Bill: WHAT'S NEXT ON THAT,
BILL?
DID IT GIVE YOU THE IMPRESSION
THE CURRENT POLICY WOULD CHANGE?
>> WELL, BOTH PARTIES ARE
OBVIOUSLY DRAWING THAT LINES IN
THE STAND AND STANDING BEHIND
THEM.
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING REPUBLICANS
DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH US.
MCCARTHY SAYS IF NANCY PELOSI
WAS GONE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
MCCARTHY TOLD ME IS IF AMERICANS
WANT A CHANGE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER THEY HAVE TO MAKE A
CHANGE POLITICALLY.
A REPUBLICAN PRIORITY WOULD BE
TO SECURE THAT BORDER.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY REPUBLICANS
DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH THEM
EVEN ON SOMETHING LIKE DACA.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Bill: GREAT REPORTING.
NICE TO SEE YOU IN WASHINGTON,